before this video begins i have new
merch represent.com super happy about
this so i think you guys will like it
check it out anyway let's on with the
video taking advice need help in life dr
pewte's here to help baby that's right i
will bestow my infinite wisdom on this
earth that but for real um yeah taking
advice let's see what we got curse as
how do you cope with our awkwardness
or specialty of mine especially when you
need to talk to a lot of people or new
people if i have to talk to a lot of
people i tend to
practice a lot i mean are you talking
about public speaking here i don't know
i don't know
i think what i tend to do subconsciously
which is a little bit cringe i tend to
smile way more than i need to
just like
this
smiling is the ultimate cope
i'm very comfortable right now
this is terrible advice i
the thing is i never thought i was that
awkward until the internet pointed out
to me so i don't really know what to say
to this get a job in customer service
and you'll get used to to talking to
dozens or hundreds of people talking oh
oh people daily yeah this is great
advice if you want to ask people if they
want mustard or ketchup on their
hamburger like what i had a job like
this it didn't help me at all what do
you mean
you just go into robotic mode
hey you want you want fries with that
you're gonna walk up to people randomly
at parties you want diet coke
i mean i guess the point here is the the
more you do something like this the more
you'll get over it slowly but surely
challenge yourself don't run away i
think is the trick just do it and you'll
realize slowly but surely it's not as
bad as you think but if you run away
it'll just become scarier and scarier
hey pewds i recently graduated high
school and i'm gonna start college soon
the thing is that i'm really not fond of
doing that but i'm doing it anyways just
to be safe what i really want to do is
work on my youtube channel make story
time animations as well stream but since
i'm just a beginner i'm obviously not
earning any money from it and college
work really reduces my time to work on
the stuff i really like to do would you
recommend that i continue doing what i
do or drop out of college sometime in
the future well i absolutely don't drop
out of college my dude listen
i was extremely lucky but i was still i
was still studying while making videos
it's entirely possible just keep it as a
fun hobby you know it doesn't have to be
your job to enjoy it
i think what a lot of people don't
realize is that as soon as your hobby
becomes your job it completely ruins the
joy of it being a hobby it is a job then
right
there's no escaping that i think
everyone has this dream that your hobby
should be your job but it can be
perfectly fine to keep a normal job and
a hobby at the same side there's no
there's no harm in that so
keep your job
keep it as a hobby if it goes better you
know great then you can start thinking
about that but i think you're a little
too early to asking this question i feel
like my parents have this extremely high
expectation of me and to be honest i
would happily have those expectations
for myself and work hard to reach them
but it's really tough when it feels like
every mistake i make makes them be more
disappointed in me i feel like i'm not
working hard to make my parents proud
anymore rather so they don't dislike me
why should i do pewter uh yeah that
sucks to have parents like that i mean
it might be worth talking to them about
this i don't know what kind of open
conversations you can have i think my
parents have high expectations of me
which i think is good but they also had
on the flip side as long as they noticed
i was trying my best it you know the
result wasn't as important as them
feeling like i was really working hard
and you know i would hope that you it
doesn't sound like you have that kind of
parents but i don't know so that's
that's why i thought maybe it's worth
talking to them about this because maybe
they're not i don't know i'm trying to
be optimistic that sounds really
i guess at the end of the day is do you
want validations for yourself or do you
want it for your parents and the answer
should be for yourself right
parents will always have expectations
for what they want of you and that
sometimes is an image that is impossible
to fit into and it sounds from what it
sounds like that's where you're at so i
would try and sort of question more what
is it that you want to that will make
you feel validated and focus on that
instead
i like how you guys are helping as well
that's really sweet sort of giving
similar advice here make yourself proud
and they will be proud yeah and maybe
try and discuss this with your parents
moving on hey felix uh how do you get
used to having lost many friends and
being forgotten seamlessly over time
uh i'm sorry i didn't mean to laugh i
just
i don't know to
this is the first time i'm reading these
questions um and they're very difficult
questions that's why i'm you know i've
definitely lost a lot of friends in my
life in my days i think that's a natural
thing uh part of life you know i'm not
close friends with the people that i
thought i would be friends forever with
so many i mean i had the best yeah this
is normal right maybe
everyone you know moves on to different
things that doesn't mean that you're
forgotten someone it seems like you're
taking it quite personally
which i don't think you should it's just
a natural thing that happens to everyone
try and think of what sort of purpose
your friendships are for you and what it
is that you find that you get out of
them if your point is to stay friends
just for the sake of being friends then
i mean it's kind of pointless
to have that friendship to begin with i
actually this reminds me i used to have
so few friends my i remember my dad just
walked in on a saturday he's like why
are you aren't you out and i was like i
don't know
and it's like you should be out with
friends and i just thought well i don't
really have any friends to call
it's funny it didn't bother me maybe i'm
a psychopath i don't know but
[Laughter]
yeah and that's why i think yeah it's
good to ask yourself what what's the
point of having their friends to you why
do they mean something you'll find
friends don't worry it takes time
if i the neighbor's kid can find friends
so can you all right i just entered
senior high school this month seeing how
tough it is already it really makes me
doubt about my future oh boy i can
relate to this except college and if i
can achieve the things i want to do not
expecting kids to see this but if
there's any advice i'd appreciate it i
wish you would expand a bit on what it
is that you want to do it's hard to
answer this question because of it i
guess you just have to ask yourself if
you're up for the challenge
i think anyone is capable of so much
more than they think they are but they
you really just have to put your mind
and soul into it and if you really
wanted to
step up i'm sure that you can do with
timothy
i'm giving you the confidence but you
have to make that choice and make the
sacrifices to get through what you want
with the grades or whatever it is that
you want it doesn't come without work
you go timothy you got it you got it man
how do you get the courage to put
yourself out on the internet and share
your life passions and talk about
anything while most of the people on the
internet don't know you the ones in real
life that do might find it weird for
someone who wants to keep their nativity
a secret they might let it out uh it
sounds stupid but it always taunts me as
an artist working on my way on the
internet and much love from romania
i think this is normal and
i wouldn't feel pressured to feel like
you have to
share your life or passions and talk
about anything on the internet that's
completely up to
everyone if that's what they want to do
some people feel comfortable with it
some people don't i remember feeling
super strange about just recording
myself without camera just my voice
it just takes a little bit of practice
to do if you're not comfortable with it
immediately it takes time to take it
step by step and you'll find sooner or
later what sort of things you do feel
comfortable about and maybe some stuff
you actually do want to keep private for
yourself so take it step by step and
don't make any rash decisions uh maybe
just a little general being
an adult advice i heard a lot of great
advice about my main concern so i guess
i'm wondering if there's things about
adulthood that surprised you or regrets
that you wish you knew better i wish i
started reading and i wish i started
working out sooner
that's it
is being an introvert really that
special or are we just trying to justify
our abundance of social anxiety
sometimes i wish i could talk to people
normally but here i am shivering at the
thought of any interaction
yeah i think this is why i get so i used
to at least get so annoyed when people
call me
awkward online because as an introvert
i'm really trying to get past that like
doing stage performances back in in the
days and
big fan meet up and all that stuff
or even shooting shows like scare
pewdiepie you know when you're in front
of all these people and as an introvert
that's kind of awkward i i want to step
up to the challenge and be like yeah i
can do it but and then someone comments
me like oh that was awkward and you're
just like ah but i
i'm trying but i think i'm just
accepting hey you know yeah i am a
little awkward that's fine what's the
big deal i it made it so much easier and
i'm i you know i'll still push myself or
whatever but at least knowing that in my
back of my mind okay it's fine it
doesn't matter
to answer your question though but if
it's really special no and that's i
guess what i meant with trying to
overcome it everyone has things that
they excel in and and maybe aren't as
good in and it's good to recognize that
so you can improve on it i don't think
being introverted is necessarily special
but i also find that it helps me gain a
lot of introspection which is something
that i really highly value and i think
it's important for your
mental growth and strength i'm not sure
you know in extroverts are excluded for
that but it's just something that i
highly value that i know feel like comes
from being an introvert dear doctor
physique we know you're growing a beard
and that's final step in becoming a
philosopher
i actually just shaved yeah it's true uh
the the beard used to be such a highly
symbolic thing for greek philosophers
that uh they would rather cut off their
head than their beard i don't remember
who said that into nihilist philosophy
i'm making a video on this because i
find it so strange people's idea of what
nihilistic philosophy is i think there's
a major misconception here of angsty
teenagers not understanding what it
means how do you find balance between
being educated on social issues and not
letting it negatively impact your own
mental health i want to be educated and
advocate for things but it takes such a
toll on me yeah i mean if you
if you uh look at your whole country's
past or everything like that you're
bound to just
feel this dread of uh guilt
i just don't think that's healthy
whatsoever uh i i think it's in our
nature especially as young people we
tend to want to find social issues as a
cause and uh we want this suffering it's
almost like a function in us trying to
find where i read this i think it was
nietzsche read nietzsche i guess how do
you get out of a rut the time period of
your life where you are unproductive to
do anything i suffer a lot of being
stuck in this timeline of my life and
every time i do something i can't really
get it done or keep procrastinating well
that's because you train yourself to be
that way and it's very easy to fall in
this trap i think we are very habitual
creatures i think and if we act a
certain way it's because we made it
comfortable for ourselves to act that
way but there's a great way to challenge
yourself in and trying things that are a
little more difficult and setting goals
for yourself to maintain those things i
don't know what it is that you want uh
to do specifically but i'm sure there's
something that you you feel like there
is that you should be doing otherwise
you wouldn't complain about being stuck
in this rut i guess it's kind of like
how the greeks saw the virtue inhabit
what was said who said it it's such a
good quote i think it was aristotle
saying that i'm butchering this quote
but it's something about virtue isn't in
doing one thing but it's in the
continuation of doing things recognizing
that how you live your life in a good
way is setting up habits that are good
for you it's not just
one small act that defines your uh your
goodness oh god yeah that's terrible
explanation but i hope it makes sense
i'm cringing at my answer sorry
finally some relationship advice i like
this girl and i strongly feel she likes
me too but she doesn't feel interested
in having a relationship what should i
do
well it might be
good to back off because it sounds like
your feelings might get hurt from this
woman
better to step aside i think if that's
the case if you really want a
relationship of course or
you know
this is a very guy advice but you know
sometimes
you just gotta get out of your system
man
do what you gotta do
all right
do what you gotta do and you know you
might find that uh you know you scored
the highest university how did you focus
on studies like that do you set your
environment for studies or set a
schedule i think all i did during this
time was studying
from the moment i woke up to the moment
i went to bed i was so into it i i don't
know why i was so competitive about it i
wanted to be the best and it i can't
explain like what unlocked that inside
me i guess i wanted to prove that i
could do it i sometimes we just get that
random spurt i wasn't always the best in
school i was actually pretty terrible in
a lot of subjects so i wanted to prove
hey i can do it if i put my mind into it
and i got really really really really
really really nerdy there's a lot of
questions about like motivation and
there seems to be a lack of it bro
everyone is unmotivated
i'm a strong proponent of that routines
is what keeps us motivated because
motivation only lasts for it's a short
spurt it's like
a certain it's a feeling you're not
going to feel like amped up and
motivated all the time but if you have a
routine set in place that when you're
not feeling motivated it's there to pick
it up for you okay i'm supposed to do
this i'm going to do this
that's not necessarily going in like
yeah i'm gonna do this it's rather okay
this is what i have to do uh so setting
those things in your life it takes a
long time to build these sort of uh uh
routines you have to stick to it set
goals for yourself big goals long goals
realizing what it is what you want and
set goals and how you wanna get there oh
i wanna i wanna learn this okay i'm
gonna spend this amount of time every
single day
to get there and also recognize that
these are my goals if i don't do this
i'm just going to go back to feeling the
way i was before so i'm
i'm setting these goals and i'm taking
it seriously i guess it's kind of how i
feel about uh working out i would always
feel socially about not working out and
maybe that's just pushing myself too far
and there's some other psychological
issues there i don't know but there was
always this anxiety of i know i should
working out because of all the health
benefits but
it's kind of i don't really want to and
but if you have that routine of saying
okay i'm gonna work out this is my
schedule and i'm gonna keep with it it's
so much easier and i never have that
feeling of oh i should be working out he
says no i just do it that's the point of
setting goals for yourself it doesn't
matter what it is it's the same
principle all right that's enough
questions answered i hope this was
helpful uh in some sense and i'll see
you guys in the next one oh i have new
merch
super hairy because of maya
represent.com pewdiepie check it out i'm
really happy with this one i think you
guys will like it too bye you thought it
was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions means our emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for
free and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this